for those of you that don't know exactly
who you are what you stand for why don't
you take a minute and just say like who
you are what you stand for what you
believe
it's Pearl
um I would say that I talk about
intersexual Dynamics on my podcast and
it talks about we talk about so many
different topics but I would say
anti-feminism anti-like modern
relationships I would say is basically
anti-feminism anti-modern relations yeah
yeah and now is modern relationships uh
symbiotic with feminism is that kind of
what you're saying yeah I would say yes
why do you think that is
why well
I just think we we've changed you a
culture where it's about me me me
instead of the family first yeah you
know how that started with a selfie it
all started with a selfie well I think
the selfie it's about yourself now
you're selfish you're taking a selfie
you're putting your stupid self face in
the in the picture it's all about
yourself what happened to us what
happened to we
that's my opinion I don't know
you know what's interesting
um they pinpoint like one of the pivotal
like moments when do the divorce rate
increased as when um women started
getting on birth control and it's funny
my grandma she she's 80 right and I saw
her last week and I asked her um she
doesn't know anything about red pill
doesn't know anything about the stats
and I asked her like why do you think
like people started to get divorced and
she told me birth control
just interesting well I'm not saying
that your good friend Rolo author of the
rational mail says that birth control is
hypergamy what does that mean meaning
if a woman gets pregnant she will
obviously assess the situation and be
like all right who's this dude that just
knocked me up okay he's a NBA basketball
player AKA Brittany Renner he's a high
value man he's Drake you know the Drake
condom hot sauce story all right this
guy I will have his baby and I'll go out
of my way to have his baby versus I was
[ __ ] up it was some dude at the bar
he's a homeless jobless whatever
abortion that's kind of what your
grandma's saying
um I don't know if her Grandma knows
Drake I mean she knows about abortion
your grandmother I mean I don't think I
don't think my Grandma knows what
hypergamy is but she was just saying
yeah yeah she was just saying like women
get the opportunity to sleep around with
no consequences so they do it no that's
exactly what it is yeah is that they
have now the the choice to say okay I'm
pregnant I've never been pregnant you've
been pregnant twice
people out there but women have a choice
to say okay let me back up it's been 30
60 90 days
I'm pregnant now okay who's the father
of the child and then hypergamy is the
what the definition of epergamy is the
act of dating up or marrying up so you
have this conscious decision to say huh
I'm not even in a relationship with this
person do I want to have Drake's baby
yes do I want to have bills baby hell no
abortion it's essentially what Grandma's
saying yeah yeah and this is why you
feel so strongly about anti-feminism
like equate the two I guess is what I'm
asking you what do you what do you mean
you're saying that you feel so strong
about anti-feminism well I just think
that was caused modern Relationships by
abortion so I'm literally trying to
marry the two thoughts oh well I mean I
just think that feminism isn't always
has been a hate group so it's always
been like freedom without the
responsibility at the expense of men
often when it comes to like I mean it
just goes back to like no consequences
so when there's birth control and I'm
not saying people will say I want to get
rid of birth control I'm not saying that
but I'm saying when you have birth
control gets rid of the consequence of
sleeping around
is what a bad thing that's a bad thing
I mean I don't think it's good
or Society by and large okay you don't
believe so
I'm in
what does that mean like people
shouldn't be having sex unless they're
dating
what do you mean
well he's asking
people should people not be having sex
unless they're dating or
single we're talking about hookup
cultures I think we're going here like
now hook up culture body count I mean
this is something that is pervasive you
know I saw a video last week about a
girl that slept with four guys in one
week you know I mean I just think that's
Madness I just think Society has gone to
like that's crazy but are you saying
that's because she's on the pill or are
you saying she could do that without
them I'm saying the pill adds to it I'm
saying abortion adds to it too I mean I
know I met someone the other seven
abortions seven oh my God at that point
you can't even tell 30 of people that
have had abortions have had it's either
one or more or two or more and they
don't produce or 40 sorry 40 of women
that have had abortions have had one or
more and so when they don't track the 60
in the future that if they will have
them so it's like how can you say it's
not a form of birth control if women are
constantly getting them again and again
and again wow so give me those stats one
more time 40 of women that have had
abortions have had one or more and
that's both in England and in the UK one
and you get more well they've had one
they've had one no like like so it's
their second division more than one
before yeah so they are perennial
habitual
abortion proponents or I mean I don't
know I mean it's just it just seems like
it's it's used as a form of a form of
hypergamy Slash birth control yeah
because and 98 of abortions are elective
yeah and I think uh 90 something percent
happened in the first two trimesters
anyway I'm not the abortion expert here
but this is essentially what you stand
for and like Grandma kind of like put it
all together with the feminism and
that's what started feminism essentially
that's what you're saying that no I
don't think birth control Story I mean
that's a whole different tangent I can
go into it yeah go into it but
um
I mean feminism started in 1888 in
Seneca Falls New York so that was when
feminism first wave feminism I mean to
vote suffrage right to work in the 50s
all that you're talking about modern day
feminism a modern woman right no I mean
I would say it's always been one
movement it's always been freedom
without responsibility
oh so you even the original feminism
movement in 18
1888 1888 in Seneca Falls New York
you're not a proponent of that movement
I mean I'm
it depends
um what did that because it like what I
would say is it's always been freedom
without responsibility so um even like
when they talked about the right to vote
see they were going on so many different
tangents but even when we talk about the
right to vote like men had to get
drafted so like that was why women
couldn't vote and I'm not saying we go
back like I think we've already gone
this far we're not going to go back at
this point but
um I just think feminism is and always
has been a hate group
hate group wow so I assume your biggest
haters are women today yeah yes yeah
okay I unpack that a little bit like
what are women telling you like you're
you must see the comments the maddest
group that I get is the fat chicks yeah
um so there was an incident where I had
a whale attack now
so I was doing Street interviews and I
was talking about like women sometimes
and I want to say like women and men can
be entitled but I've just found that
it's more women so like this woman on
the street was talking about she felt
like oh I can't walk home alone at night
and my whole point was men can't walk no
why are you walking home alone at night
it's in a dangerous area and this
triggered her she just got real mad
because I was just saying like no one
can walk like what are you gonna do walk
down a bad area if you're a guy you're
gonna get attacked too anyways so she
got mad she knocks the mic out of my
hand she's like I'll have you oh [ __ ]
I'm sorry I'll have you you slag I'll
have you you slag and I live in London
so I didn't know what a slag meant but I
knew I was being insulted so and then I
was like and
well you're you're running away
and yeah and so that got me
so then all these girls got mad because
and then another podcast I was like 300
pounds is a lot and I was just like I
feel like if you're 300 pounds you
probably shouldn't expect someone that
makes six figures you know I mean that's
just a high expectation if you're that
fat yeah and yeah so then just came for
me they started making videos about me
and this was like non-stop they harassed
they they harassed my family they
messaged my sisters like that has been
the most triggered group I would say oh
and you know what
I said 300 pounds is a lot I stand on
that yeah that's a lot of weight oh I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna push back on
that at all but I assume when you're
using the word you know what you're
getting yourself into she started it she
called she called me a slag first what's
a swag I know what is it oh yeah yeah
and she also called me ugly too so I was
just like it's like I don't I don't
start fights but I will finish it and so
if anything if anything I should
apologize to the whales and the sea yeah
because those are beautiful majestic
creatures and I compared them
so you're so that's a compliment is what
you're saying
to monetize on a daily
worm if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible